i would not want that
i would not want him in my changing room
i'm sorry i wouldn't i would feel weird
it's like essentially
so you're telling me the difference
between that those two pictures so he
was on top and yeah he was on top and
about him and essentially
um
the difference between those two
pictures is
short hair he was a man long hair he's a
woman
and i guess his face is a little it's
like not even feminine
like does that look like a girl to you
no
i'm going to get you guys canceled
this might be the broadcast to do it
there are some there are some women who
have manly features as well yeah that's
what i was gonna say yeah
you know what i'm i'm thinking of a
couple and i still think even the girls
with manly features
if
if i if i knew if i was a man
and i was a sketchy one i'm not saying
that she is i was a schedule and i was
an athlete and i'm like okay i'm good
i'm good at men's sports but i'm not
that great if i didn't have
no more conscious
i would do it i'd be like oh i'm
transitioning and dominate women's
sports and then after i do what i need
to do in that and get whatever money i
need to change like i actually want to
detransition and just go back and be
like
and i'm not saying and like me saying
that i can i can feel like someone's
gonna be like that's disrespectful blah
blah blah just like
if it
if that's if that's all it takes is just
to take uh i know estrogen i know taking
hormone pills is a lot but if there's no
if i can get in cahoots with a doctor
with people and say hey like when i make
my money i'm gonna pay you off so if
someone comes if a new reporter asks if
they need physical evidence that i am
transitioning to a woman provided for
them and i got you i'll pay you off once
i get all this money
and i may i may just have god gave
someone just gold right there
well and and it's like for narcissists
like who because i i've talked to tran
like trans people that agree they're
like no why on earth would we be in that
league what what typically yeah no
there's like like blair
wool i foreign
um
but like
and even caitlyn jenner like she says
that oh no like we should not be allowed
in those leagues
why why is it that like it's like the
like i honestly think a rational trans
person like really would agree and would
understand but like it's like the ones
that have to be the center like i feel
like he wants to be the center of
attention like he knew when he switched
over he would win the league he knew
he'd be the center of attention like i i
don't
i just can't
even assume good intent like i don't
believe he had good intentions because i
don't understand how you can be next to
like this girl
and genuinely look yourself in the
mirror and think that's fair
yeah did you see the picture where
uh she was on the first podium and like
everybody else was on like the third
podium i don't know the story behind it
um
but it was essentially like they were
saying
in my in my opinion that i was like oh
like
we're not even like near this person
and physically and so it's just like
we're just gonna automatically be third
because that's how that's how it's
always going to be it's like
we're never going to be first unless
she
i don't even know if
if it came to a point where they were
leah is her name lea or lisa leah leah
is physically
out of shape to where that
some
biological wouldn't be able to beat her
it's like
the wingspan and swimming your your
arm length is
something that is if you got it if you
got long orangutan arms you are going to
dominate and swim because
that's what you use your arms and your
legs yeah and so
and then like look at like this coach
right here
how can how can the coach like coach how
does he look
but the coach could
and the coach could also be benefiting
from this
he get a stipend oh you you're one of
the first
coaches to allow trans women to swim wow
we want to give you this we want to give
you that and there's like there's perks
with having i'm not calling her when i
say this i'm not calling her this but
there's perks with having a new shiny
toy or something new like oh attention
is currency yeah like oh new okay let's
publicity news uh
news reporters being on um
news shows being on
podcasts being on whatever and having
people talk about it and people googling
and searching your name the situation
it's like it's generating stuff and
people are going to want to come and
talk to you about the situation so there
was
definitely
some perk with that coach allowing that
to happen
i just like these grown ass man like
i just like can't i'm like you get out
there and swim against me
i'm like you have to be a beta ass dude
to allow this like i'm sorry you if as a
man
like i you can i don't know how you can
look yourself in the mirror and train
this grown dude do you think he even
truly respects from women's sport as a
coach dog
do you think our coach would allow that
i don't think he would i don't think i
don't think he would i think he'd like
to walk away and be like
we do below on numbers
oh my god okay
should i come this week should i come
next week
yo please
so what what